[Musique]
c'est soir de grande première à saint
pétersbourg et ils sont tous là en
chariot lui rappeur de leurs adulé par
des millions de jeunes de moscou aux
villes les plus reculés de l'acide qui
les réunit sur cette même scène
si l'arrivée en salles du film bill qui
l'usc la jeune est impressionnante
histoire du pied droit en russie son
pouvoir et son influence
[Musique]
cette nouvelle génération d'artistes
mètres de l'arrêt mais du franc-parler a
connu une ascension vertigineuse
autrefois copie conforme du rap
américain
leur approche à trouver sa propre voie
[Musique]
et ce grâce à des jeunes artistes comme
mylène fiodor alias auxi myron qui
chantent au nom de la liberté contre la
corruption c'est chose du nord-kivu
coach mais lancement du film tombe à
point nommé alors que le rap est mise à
mal
qui de plus en plus sur des jouets par
les autorités dany là et hellman rap
depuis qu'ils ont 17
ils en ont 29 ils ne comprennent pas ce
nouvel acharnement show the differences
in an quand intel est un émulateur une
politique coûte news poutine ou
n'importe quel politicien doit
comprendre s'il est intelligent
le caractère de masse de cette musique
dans notre pays hélas du poids avec la
valeur ne peuvent pas lutter contre elle
d'autant plus qu'elle n'entre même pas
en contradiction avec les lois
peut-être mais elle dérange de plus en
plus et ce serait son influence néfaste
sur la jeunesse qui aurait justifié
l'annulation d'une série de concerts par
des gouvernements locaux dans plusieurs
villes de russie
l'arrestation du rappeur populaire face
qui alors qu'ils protestaient contre
cette censure sur le toit d'une voiture
a été un véritable point tournant et une
sonnette d'alarmé pour le gouvernement
de vladimir poutine explique le critique
musical arthur gasparian machin
le président poutine qui jusqu'ici ne
s'était jamais souci du phénomène a même
réuni ses conseillers en culture dans
l'espoir d'apprivoiser la barre propre
correcte sexe on a reporté et première
entreprise sur trois piliers de cette la
drogue la protestation
la prévenue le vieux jce les niveaux aux
menaces tonnes à vide
toulouges novasque aurait alors s'il
nous est impossible de les interdire il
faut trouver une passion de le prendre
en main un accord de vladimir poutine
cela fait pourtant des années que le rap
est sorti non en russie avec les
fameuses bateaux dont auximines et le
branchant le 1703 qu'il a tatoué sur le
coup et non seulement l'année de la
fondation de saint pétersbourg in italia
c'est aussi le nom de ce petit bar où
les plus célèbres bateaux se sont
disputés
kiprop joute verbale qui est une poésie
moderne et qui parle de nos réalités du
le propriétaire à l'excès des combats
visionné des centaines de millions de
fois sur les chaînes comme une tour en
russie est aussi traditionnellement la
majorité de ces artistes semblent être
politique
après ils ont déboulé de poèmes et
dernière ce véritablement changé la
tendance ni voilà aujourd'hui solidaires
pour lutter contre toutes tentatives de
répression
iouri chevtchouk est un monument du rock
des années 80 son groupe ddt a vaincu la
censure alors que la musique était sous
le contrôle du gouvernement se vident
les chefs peut-être nos sages dac
aujourd'hui le pouvoir veut faire la
même chose implanté sa culture mais il
ne peut pas nous ni je vois les bovins
et de jeunes gens sont différents
poutine a dit qu'il veut les apprivoiser
il ne peut pas apprivoiser la liberté
noka bois de l'igf
bref que la musique n'est propre demeure
peu des derniers espaces de liberté en
russie et ce qui est de plus en plus
clair c'est que d'apprivoiser cette
génération branchée en quête d'oxygène
est une énigme pour le régime de
vladimir poutine
the bigs 2
[Musique]
jusqu'où ira le gouvernement pour
contrôler leur musique ce n'est pas
encore clair mais dans un pays où les
citoyens sont gavés par la télévision
d'état et la propagande leur a laissé
pendant qu'ont choisi leur camp